how do you increase your total
adjustable market like there's four ways
to increase it there's five ways to
adjust it so you can go up market which
means you're selling to bigger versions
of the same thing so let's say i was
helping hair salon owners i could help
people who have chains of hair salons or
i could help franchisors or license
orders of hair salons it'd be much a
much smaller demo but they'd be much
bigger clients it'd be enterprise right
i could go down market which would be
selling smaller versions which would be
like i could sell hairstylists right if
i want to go down market from there
people who aspire to be hair stylists
right so it's like a pyramid you can go
adjacent market which is what's similar
to hairstylist that probably has similar
wants and needs so probably like lash
salon that would be an adjacent market
or i could go broader so broader is
where you take all adjacent markets
under one umbrella which would be beauty
right so be like i help all beauty tie
brick and mortar businesses right that
would be going broader and so those are
the four ways you can increase the total
addressable market of whatever thing
that you're serving